belfast is a city of stories and
particularly at the end of the 1960s it
went through an incredible tumultuous
phase in its history
you wouldn't want to be the old man out
in the street talk to my phone and i'll
kill you i and my family were part of
that and action cairn
has written very very very closely about
his own life and about his own emotions
about growing up in belfast during that
time his own family their emotions his
emotions and the subsequent
outcome of that
when i read the script i was astounded
by
what kenneth written and what i knew
because we came from the same culture
and what he wrote was suddenly unleashed
all these memories of not just of places
of locations
of people of my people this is obviously
such a personal story for ken i mean it
is uh
his story or certainly very close to his
story many of the events really happened
and that were pretty true to them ken
particularly did not want this to be a
documentary about his life this was a a
cinematic memory they're all very
imaginative they're all very generous
with the way they bring their own
experience to the roles including their
own experience of family we took a
weekend in belfast ken myself harris
and martin first a.d and we walked the
streets we walked the streets of his
childhood life that was hugely
beneficial and very emotional at times
we were able to you know take the
journey that he'd taken every day from
home to school and through the park and
back again
and the conversations that we had during
those walks were really the sort of
ken's phenomenal brief to me about how
how that world
was remembered by him the story of the
film is what happens to
one family inside that street as the
violence intensifies
the possibility
of escape
rears its head
and the choice between whether you stay
in a community that operates the idea
that it takes a village to raise a child
and where there is much happiness and
much sense of who the family is
extraordinary extended family many
cousins many aunts and uncles suddenly
everyone just normal hard-working people
were having to
make these big decisions about choosing
sides
and aligning themselves with something
this underlying possibility of violence
flaring up immediately and very
traumatically will they stay
will they go
can they negotiate what many families
find um very difficult and many people
find their very difficult uh change
mommy we made the supermarket where did
you get that i told you we're leaving
the supermarket you're what
you wait right there young man
why did you take that washing powder
it's biological
oh
did you hear me and if you ever ever do
anything like that again can you you
hear me in your young madam if you ever
dragged my son into something like this
again i will beat you black and blue
until you never get home again can you
hear me
all right
put it back at them hey woman we don't
put things back
that's not the statement we're trying to
make billy come on the army you're
coming come on out
get out of grab traffic
[Music]
time to get out of here don't try
anything so you two are going to
guarantee safe passage for me and my man
you try to run i put a bullet in your
son's head
ah here he comes the lone ranger
right now
i can see your kindness a little
discipline
you let them go now
no i think if i do one of them soldiers
gonna take my head off
if they don't i will
over their dead bodies
one of the things that was really
possible at that time was to be
just like the riot at the beginning of
the film caught up instantaneously in
something that even a few seconds ago
didn't seem to be happening i remember
that my breath was very very uh shallow
and there was this sense that if you
somehow you were in great danger if you
turned around there's this yell get
something pick something choose so what
i mean i you know and then i started to
feel mentally i'm going what do you do
what like what's the least defensive
thing to take what can i do that somehow
it isn't ungracious you know so i'm
don't take chocolate don't take all the
selfish things and but you're being
pushed and shoved all the time and now
you're realizing you're in a tide of
people you need to find a way to get out
so the only way to get it is to take
something and then i suddenly thought
what do we do the family something for
the family then i thought well if it's
the family do get a big pack of washing
powder because surely that'll be useful
there was only one take that we could do
because once the shop was destroyed that
was it like there was no kind of
resetting it everyone's running into the
shop yanking things off the shelves and
this wasn't planned but one of the
rioters accidentally knocked over all
the shelves and they all toppled into
each other but then we couldn't get out
because all of the
the way we were supposed to go out we
couldn't because all of the shelves were
were knocked over so we sort of had to
go the other way
folks always have a problem with change
but do you better get used to it mister
people like me run this time now
and it's people like you
that bring us all done
i see my son
uh my youngest son and my wife in sort
of captivity
and we have this
big standoff moment in the street that
is very much inspired by westerns of
long long ago
you know the scene is about the way in
which the acceleration of this kind of
violence can be so intense and so swift
that before you know where you are in
this case at least through the mind of
this nine-year-old
uh they're in a standoff
as if as if it were a wild west town as
if it were a scene from a western that
we've watched this boy see during the
course of the film big hand move along
near in high noon
he made a bow while in state's prison
shock and fear of the riot was so great
that the boy begins to interpret the
violence that he's witnessing
through
his imagination and he's seen high noon
and in the film we had planted the scene
of high noon and ken and i very
deliberately had chosen shots such as
the high angle of gary cooper walking
away so that when we came to this riot
scene ken had covered it a little bit
like high noon so we could suddenly go
after all that sort of social realism
cutting we could now go wide and high
and pod the hero returns and
high noon begins
[Music]
it's remarkable how when you do look at
a a a western film and you see those
streets uh
how much they look like the terrace
streets in belfast and we took all the
influences and the references that we
had at that point for turning something
that was kinetic and energetic and
handheld into something that was just
this kind of locked off confrontation
much like a western film i mean that
scene was really interesting because it
did have that sort of heightened
um
you know standoff
sense to it or feel to it and
you know we were coming out and there's
all of that tension and that fear and ma
realizes i think in that moment
just how much danger she's put her
children in
because of some principle that she
thinks is important which she realizes
very quickly in that moment that it
isn't you know
it's gonna be all right
i'll talk to the committee
get this fixed
there'll be no more baller
i could say to my face in that shop
window
when i was running down the street and
dragging them for a kid's pain
and i was looking at the marriages no
i don't see him face
i asked
myself what the hell am i doing
and then
i was sick
i can come every morning night
i realized
i don't think
it really matters anymore
so tomorrow
when i'm back and i don't even look
right
i think it's
that she realizes the peril
that
her children are in and i have to say
it's one of the most riveting riveting
performances by anyone on any film i've
ever seen i was
mesmerized in the viewfinder and in
tears i think my mother got to that
point of going what have i done from
being fearful for my safety she's
dragged us both she pregnant and her son
back into a situation where uh we're at
greater risk than we ever were it was
like a sort of bell being sounded for
what was going to be the tipping point
in our experience of belfast which is
things had gone too far now the madness
has taken over yeah it was a hugely
hugely important literally life-changing
moment in my life and in our film
it's the moment that dictates the way
the rest of the story will be told
internally i think those decisions for
families to move for the migrant story
to begin the migrant narrative to
dominate their lives for that period of
innocence that we might enjoy for a
while in our lives to be
suddenly replaced by this notion
that
as you navigate the rest of your time
passing through this world one really
key thing that you're going to have to
start dealing with is loss
in the wake of great loss comes
a great desire to assert the
beauty and the wonders and the joy of
life i don't think you can watch this
film without thinking about
your own family it's not a very easy
thing to do you know to create something
so universal by being very specific but
he did it beautifully
i mean this is this is ken's family
so if belfast does anything i hope
it puts a smile on the face of people so
that they can believe that what i've
just described is possible rather than
some kind of dream
in stories like this maybe we understand
that we are not alone when we look at
these reflections of other lives
i think to be childlike in the way we
look at life is sometimes very valuable
it needn't make us sentimental or naive
sometimes it can just make us happy
[Music]
you